这家分享一条超级有用的知识
它都不是知识 它是一套超级实用的系统
就这条系统可以帮助你的收入
翻背
比如我不管啊 我们老合级 老合级 麻烦你
认真的重头看到 如果看不懂再看一遍
然后
把它坏一坏 一定要把它弱势到
行动中 这条知识是非常非常有用的
我们大多数人 其实每天都是在重复制裁的工作
每天都清理用每年都清理用到重新开始
就是你做的事情是没有复利的
但是我的话每天差不多只需要花十分钟的时间
复制年梯就
每过一段时间
然后我的收入
就会翻背
昨天的知识不里面给大家演示我
我是怎么做到了呢
叫做
复利散步伐 你照着我做
你又可能只是因为你在初期的时候你的收入可能会
就是没那么快 可能时间长一点
但是随着你的时间的期待
这个复利的效果会越来越好
怎么做
就散步
第一步
你要做一个成果 样机
要什么意思我会把大家解释
你也可以把它成这位魔法
第一件事情
第二件事情
公开你的过程这是第二件事情
然后第三件事情
一旦发现这件事情
需要重复
那么去更新你的成果样机
不太理解了吧
然后我来给大家解释一下我是怎么做的
其实我每天
拍视频只需要花十分钟
我们很多人是些闻子搞的然后还要去
什么就我们的办法什么时候开始做
我跟大家讲就是我拍视频是拿起相机就开始拍
然后拍花了以后然后把那个东西生成
一条给我们给大家复控
拍到了吗
为什么我拿下就可以拍的
因为拍摄短视频它是有很多版的
拿我来说我会把拍摄短视频
分成很多个种类比如说这条视频
我是给大家分享原则的
这条视频给大家分享理念的
这条视频是非常正值的这条视频是非常干货的
9例子
干货十超的短视频
基本上它会有一个模拒把这个模拒什么呢
就是我说的成果样机
什么呢
就是
有一个样机要是这样的
当你分享干货的时候
就是希望别人照得去做的
那么你照到这个做就会产生这个结果
那么就会有一个模拒把这个模拒通常是这样的
口波模拒
总是这样的
首先把拥护细节的
第二件事情指出
我们痛点的场景就如果我们做这个事情可能有痛点啊
要不然怎么能穿这位干货呢
肯定是有痛点啊怎么做不舒服啊
男生收啊对吧
但是我有一个好几个方案这个方案是怎么解决的
最后一条进去
大概是这个样子
所以我是有结果的
那么我在拍摄的时候呢我本身就有结果
所以我只需要上来就跟你讲说OK
我的关系联人人了吗
比如说我今天要跟大家分享说
很多人资率是资贊这不下来的
所以
一开始就是一个 przede bible的
不要太资
软后就开始说痛点对吧你平时是不是
想但是做做做就多不下去呀
这不是痛点吗然后我告诉我你去个方案怎么就办
就减日少你的那个工作量就把那个
每天要你要完成那个度啊
降到
我每天做一个伙伯传我们每天都是不是比如我
会许让他讲上习惯然后一点一点一点一点点点一下量然后最後一个进去
是不是
所以其实我拍照的时候的话是不需要去做准备的
上来就可以拍一面是我们的版的
然后呢给大家说的好玩家事啊就是我家这些他刚出来的时候
然后有人问家这些他怎么这样的
我看到一个读书博主说给他怎么解释的
说
他那个书就是短视频的一个核击
对不对呢
你不能说得错了
因为表现是就是这样的但是我告诉你真相是什么
真相是一开始
我就是有结果的
然后我每天在拍短视频的时候
就是为这本书创造书产
给你看到的吧
我是我和你们不太一样的情况是什么呢就是你们是先先搞在做
我是什么呢我就是上来就开始拍拍完以后
然后把那个内容直接任给AI
然后这个AI本我本身就结果我们大家看到吗就是
我说最后干过是什么
然后这是属于原则的还是属于案例的还是属于行动的对吧
然后于一句话要解释是什么然后动作实操动作是什么
干过是什么大家看到吗
就是这个样子
然后你会发现
拍完以后仍然AI资动把它变成我的内容
然后这个内容在打开
那边就是一个完整的就是我的那个
要讲的那个那个东西打开的吗
他就会变成一个知识轻体
一个知识块,一个知识块
就我原来是每天写点什么现在是每天缩点什么
说的这个东西
资动的就会变成各种知识情况
然后再给大家看一个好玩的东西啊你像我啊的话呢我是这样的
我每天都要去学习都要去思考
然后我让我学习思考的东西我就会去写小端文字
然后这个文字自动帮我双方这个结构看到吗
这是原则卡啊原则这个原则什么啊在什么产的情况下使用
然后怎么用然后进去你看都会这样的
所以你们现在知道吗
这是我拍着在这里的时候是这样的
就是我每天会有很多这样的知识块和知识轻体
然后呢很多的我都知道我会有内部视频会议
然后我还会有周二的直播对吧
大家都知道我这个周二的话呢我会有直播给大家看一个知识
不要东西吧
对吧
给大家看一个知识的东西看到吗
我会有一个我会有知识这个知识播里面
旧然是内容啊然后这个内容都可以打开了看到吗
所以各位
我每天都会有很多知识块
然后的话呢我每周的话呢都会有一个内部的这个分享会根据老伙
基本的问题然后我还会打看家语的什么情况
我有针对性能给大家去讲一些讲一些相关的知识
然后会想哦老伙你们在这一个的问题
然后在那儿有一个的问题然后这个问题的话呢可以怎么做
它就变成了我的知识块
然后晚上的时候我就随便拍一条视频这条视频拿过来以后
你不是随便啊根据大家情况
所以你会发现我拍的视频都是和我们内部的那个老伙女的情况
来来这个来相批配的所以就看有很多老伙女说
我刚想到这个时候胡德国就讲的这个的就是因为我知道你遇到什么的问题我会讲
然后就变成一个知识警惕所以看每天都是一个知识块
然后每周就是一个更大的知识块
然后每个月又是一个更大的知识块
然后每个月段时间我就会出一本书
对吧
然后大概遇到的问题就会把个结极
然后有些东西就会变成变成魔法
对
变成魔法
就是你遇到什么情况下你该怎么做
对
所以各位看明白的吗
就是当你把每次你做的这个工作
想办法把它变成魔法
变成流程变成自动化的东西
就是在什么情况下
我怎么做
可以产生什么的结果
中间的变量是什么
挺好 第二个部分
然后遇到的问题的过程中
你就把这个过程你怎么就就问着这个过程
公开的话
第三个就是当你
就是遇到重複的部分的时候
或者遇到问题的时候
然后你就会把你当前那个魔法
把那个流程你的那个系统
然后再去更新
版本一般码而版本三般的事
然后你会发现你是在用系统工作
然后你这个系统是不断
不断不断不断升级的
所以作为我来说
我每天的工作不是就是
清零了 老从来是
我每天的工作在以前的机会上
然后用系统散出的
十分钟 复制明天 复制明天 复制明天
然后我的收入就会
所以各位体会一家什么叫做复定
我在价值信码这边处理的专门写到了
人生就像古选球
先捆一个很小的学校
然后找到一个很长的波
很吃的学
每天往前会的一步